well today is transvisibility day which
celebrates the accomplishments of those
who identify as trans non-binary or
other gender many in our local lbgt
communities say that there needs to be
more awareness we spoke with the
president of las vegas pride brady
mcgill who says showing support can be
as simple as a kind gesture
whenever you're at an event and they say
look at your neighbor and you know say
something nice or introduce yourself and
understand that there isn't so much us
in them or so much difference between
everyone we're all trying to get through
the day and be successful
well one of the most visible members of
the community is our current miss nevada
cataluna enriquez she also talked about
the importance this day holds
i think it's important because we have a
history as a community being erased and
this day is about celebration of
your authenticity and what you've
accomplished but also bringing awareness
to what we still
need to work on we matter so much
because we're just like anyone else
we're all people
and she has accomplished a lot the
center on maryland parkway also has many
resources supporting our trans community
and you can find out more information
about the center at
dot com